Thank you all for joining us this afternoon for another talks at Google event.
We're very thrilled to have Alison being from lonely planet,
uh,
to speak to us today about high impacts travel.
And she's the author of over 45 books for lonely planet specifically for us
locally here,
the San Francisco Coastal California ones among others.
And so she'll talk about her experiences writing for lonely planet and when
she's not doing that,
she also helps Google out with our,
our brand studio and works and rights for several other publications nationwide
as well.
So please join me in welcoming Alison to Google.
Thanks.
So,
um,
we're going to be talking a little bit today about high impact travel.
We as,
as you know,
um,
you can't,
uh,
by the time you arrive in an airplane,
you already have a huge carbon footprint to offset and um,
and travel is more satisfying when it's a positive exchange because nobody likes
to be a burden or show up empty handed.
When a friend invites you to dinner,
you just automatically ask what you can bring and making that contribution,
it feels really good.
So when you travel to an unfamiliar place,
you don't even know who to ask,
what.
You could bring a showing up with nothing to offer,
gets things started on the wrong foot.
You've already got that carbon footprint to think about.
Um,
and it feels like a lopsided transaction.
It's a drain on local resources and it feels awkward.
So to make a positive impression,
sometimes we show up with a kind of a token gift.
I'm a San Francisco giants tee shirt,
maybe,
um,
three time world series champions,
you know,
well,
neither did my lonely planet editor in London.
He was not very impressed.
It was like baseball.
We have cricket.
So,
um,
yeah,
it went over better in a Moroccan village and the High Atlas Mountains where I
brought a tee shirt a and it was promptly torn up into strips and woven into her
rug.
So it's not what I pictured,
but you know.
Okay.
Um,
but it was a terrible flop in Italy where,
um,
the horrified Italian friend I gave it to,
uh,
gave me a lecture saying,
you need to,
yeah,
Americans need to make your tee shirts fit more tightly.
And he was like,
for the sake of humanity,
you know,
fix your fashion.
So,
uh,
I learned the hard way.
But you know,
as a travel writer,
that's my job.
I make mistakes so that you don't have to make them.
So don't bring the t shirts.
Um,
bring something else,
brings something more meaningful.
Like what,
so I'm glad you asked the first thing you can bring his suitcase space.
So travelers often pride themselves traveling light,
but they're missing out on an opportunity to connect with people in their
destination because carrying just a little extra weight is a small but tangible
act of kindness that creates powerful bonds.
And there are two important things.
You probably have room for it in your suitcase.
One is specific supplies or in kind donations for a destination nonprofit.
Be Sure to ask what that nonprofit needs most.
Um,
you know,
don't assume that San Francisco giants tee shirts or Google swag or whatever you
happen to have on hand is going to be welcome,
especially if you don't have enough to go around.
This is a,
uh,
an orphanage that I visited in Ethiopia and,
um,
uh,
definitely didn't need,
um,
San Francisco giants tee shirts,
but donations were most welcome.
MMM.
Last summer when I was invited to work on a public awareness campaign for the
Ethiopian Midwives Association,
I asked what hospital supplies might be helpful.
They asked me to bring pediatric breathing tubes,
which are inexpensive here,
but really hard to come by there and they're essential to rescue newborns with
respiratory problems.
Okay.
At the time I was working at Apple,
um,
and when I told colleagues there that what I was doing,
they wanted me to,
they wanted to send tubes to.
So I found out the maximum number I could carry and I weighed my luggage to the
last ounce and all of those tubes have been put to use already.
And let me say,
not one of those was woven into a rug.
In fact,
they were used by the doctors you see in this photo.
This is,
um,
uh,
birth ceremony that I was invited to attend and Ethiopia.
And if I look a little awkward,
it's because I had a terrible cold that day and I was trying not to touch
anything to make the baby's sick.
But the doctor said,
don't worry,
you're fine.
It'll be good for the antibodies,
for the babies.
So there you go.
Doctors.
Um,
here's something you're probably already doing.
Uh,
tell colleagues and friends where you're going and ask that people who lived in
that area,
if you could take them for coffee or lunch,
uh,
to get their suggestions so far,
that's mostly benefiting you,
right?
But at lunch,
if there's anything they might like you to deliver to their friends or family
while you're there,
ask nothing huge.
Just momentos photos,
letters,
maybe a birthday gift for a kid and deliver it in person.
This is a really meaningful gesture.
Many people with family abroad can't get away for visits very often.
And many people are concerned about reentry to the u s right now.
Even if your colleague or friend says no things,
they won't forget your kindness.
This is a photo of a inside of a guest house where I stayed in Ethiopia and the,
these are items that previous guests had sent to the host.
She had a thing for baskets and tin ware and tea sets and had some from all
over.
Um,
I brought her Benadryl cause she had allergies and um,
was really suffering from high pollen counts while I was there.
And uh,
she liked the Benadryl and I'm invited back so that worked
okay.
If they do give you a Momento to deliver,
that's a great way to make new friends or instant relatives in an unfamiliar
place.
When my best friend was living in Zimbabwe,
a guy she was dating,
visited San Francisco and he brought me a bundle of letters from my friend and a
colleague,
a collage he had made about a trip they took together.
Smart move.
That's one way to win the approval of your girlfriend's best friend.
They're now married and as their friend,
I had the honor of being the justice of the peace at their wedding ceremony.
That's me right there.
That's that.
Okay.
So your suitcase is fully loaded.
Nice.
Now.
What else can you bring?
Yeah,
research skills.
So while the assumption here,
I'm guessing you know how to search online probably better than anyone on the
planet.
So I'm about to tell you something that you already know,
especially all you product people.
Um,
to maximize positive impact,
you must do advanced research,
um,
before you even buy a ticket research to figure out where you want to go,
where you want to stay,
what you want to eat,
what you want to do,
and use impact as a filter and pro tip here,
lonely planet flags,
hotels,
restaurants,
sites,
stores,
bars and other venues with a proven commitment to sustainability in our books to
just look for the leaf icon.
Okay,
so maybe you don't want to power search on your day off.
I get that,
but don't count on just showing up and asking a local for pointers in Venice,
locals off often complained to me that tourists,
we're always asking them for directions.
At first I thought they were exaggerating until I did the math.
Even if every tourist as for directions,
only once each Phoenician would be asked on average three times a day.
And Venetian directions are complicated.
There are hundreds of foot bridges and canals.
It takes time to answer and that gets to be an imposition.
So I made sure are lonely planet Venice maps were really thorough and I also
tourists to consider getting lost part of the adventure.
Um,
I like to think maybe some Venetians are being asked for directions only twice a
day now.
And here you can see some of the difficulty that Google maps is up against with
satellite imagery.
Tried to show where streets end in Venice,
but you know,
we walk those roots.
Um,
also when you do get information from a local,
say thanks,
then stealth,
the leaf fact check that information,
even with the best intentions,
some locals will cheerfully give you the wrong information as this happened to
you.
Okay.
Um,
they assume they know all the best places in their town,
but the truth is we get a lazy in our backyards were comfortable here.
We can't always be tracking sustainable restaurant practices or nonprofit
initiatives,
especially when it's sunny out.
Oh,
by the way,
these guys are the proud owners of a lonely planet leaf icon.
They have practice sustainable fishing,
uh,
support,
sustainable fishing.
They serve exclusively.
Venetian food is El Outco in Venice and that's Francesco and his son Mateo
behind him.
Quite a team.
I interviewed them.
That's how I know their names.
Otherwise I'm usually in Cognito,
so I know all too well.
The problem of potentially I'm overlooking something in your own backyard.
I think I know my city of San Francisco until I set out to write the lonely
planet guide to San Francisco and it turns out I know my neighborhood pretty
well and I know the path I take to and from work.
Everything else requires intensive research.
So I Google search like crazy.
I interview people,
I visit places I uncover through research,
um,
eavesdrop heavily.
I'm listening.
If you're in that restaurant with me,
I'm probably trying to hear whether or not you're liking your food.
Um,
and I ask questions of everyone.
I meet at a destination,
for example,
recent research indicated that many diners were complaining about a Newish
restaurant in San Francisco called Calla that for adding it flat,
20% service fee.
So I went to Calla in Kognito to eat dinner there and I asked people there about
it.
Um,
my server was especially glad I asked her directly because it's important to her
and she feels it's been misconstrued online.
I hear that kind of thing can happen.
Um,
turns out that they're fixed service fee is part of a city program to
rehabilitate people who have been incarcerated for nonviolent crimes,
usually drug related,
ensuring a consistent income so that they can get back on their feet.
And with substance abuse treatment programs,
the story checks out.
So now I can eat a Kela and I will because it's that good and I can feel good
about that service fee and I can recommend it to you in good conscience.
So you filled your luggage,
you've done your research to figure out where you can have an impact without
entirely leaving it up to the locals to educate you.
This is all good,
but there's something else you may be able to offer.
Okay.
A willingness to go the extra mile or 30 every dollar you spend in rural areas
is circulated through the community four to 10 times more than in cities.
This is something we discovered when I was at Airbnb.
The travelers economic impact in rural areas is exponential.
But looking at travel industry data,
we also discovered that most people don't venture more than two hours beyond
city limits.
Okay?
That's a lost opportunity for rural areas,
but it's our loss as travelers too.
We're missing out on some really enriching experiences.
An absolutely beautiful places.
Sometimes these places are not set up for travelers,
so you have to do extra research to find out where to stay,
what to do and what to eat.
This is a first communion that we stumbled into and Kampala,
Chapala Mexico,
um,
and were invited to participate
and it's just a few hours outside of muscle on about two and a half.
And by the way,
this previous image as well,
two and a half hours from Rome and said town of Sodano in Tuscany.
So not everybody can do this extra bit of research,
but you can because you are Google.
So look,
I'm not saying it's easy.
Um,
once I was assigned by lonely planet to find sustainable tourism options in the
remote Ibu Gomez Valley and Morocco's high atlas mountains,
previous additions of lonely planet,
Morocco mentioned that it was a beautiful place,
ideal for hiking,
but it sounded kind of scary.
A road's washed out,
food could be scarce and few people spoke European languages or Arabic.
By then I had already seen one San Francisco giants tee shirt torn to shreds.
So I knew I had to do my research before I came.
Okay.
So I hired a Tasha head speaking guy from the area with a four wheel drive car.
And together we visited villages carved out of cliff faces.
We asked people in village elders,
what do you do here?
What would you like people to know about this place?
Are their talents or skills you'd like to share?
And I asked them all the same question we're trying to answer today.
If people would like to repay your hospitality,
how can they best do that?
Working in this collaborative way with villagers.
We met along the valley.
We were able to find ways to support initiatives they'd had in the works for
years.
By the time we left the valley,
there were working models in place for an afterschool t program at a center for
disabled adults in [inaudible].
There was a postcard pen pal project to support language acquisition for Eco
Trekking guides and Toboggan and there were go cheese tastings with a women's
goat herd collective,
which they started against the will of their parents.
By the way,
six years later,
these programs are all flourishing travelers.
Financial support and overwhelmingly positive social media posts have helped
expand accessibility for disabled people in the valley and created new jobs
through ECO travel.
Okay.
The women's goat cheese cooperative has tripled in size and received
international slow food prices for their cheese.
Roads have even improved much to the relief of the local donkeys,
and that's the thing about sustainable travel.
It's not as difficult as you might think to be a trailblazer.
All I needed to do was go a bit further out of my way and ask a few more
questions than I typically ask and when more people go further and ask more,
we can all accomplish even more.
It's exponential.
Here's how I know that last time I was in Morocco,
I ran a work session with Peace Corps volunteers to identify ways to involve
travelers in local development efforts.
They brought it back to their communities who held their own work sessions.
Morocco is also the biggest peace corp site in the Middle East and that
information has now been shared with sites across the Middle East.
I also got a lot out of,
it.
Turns out that sustainable travel road trips are totally bonding experiences.
Mohamed nor the colleague who accompanied me as a driver in translator is now a
friend of mine for life and as the result of our travels,
he's moved to the Ibu Gomez Valley.
He started his own eco travel business and now trains in mentors,
Eco travel guides.
Like I said,
exponential impact.
Okay.
Okay,
so now you've got a full suitcase.
You've done your research on impact.
You're ready to go further and ask more.
Excellent.
I can almost feel your exponential coming almost.
There's one more thing you can bring with you.
A passion or belief that transcends borders.
This could be a big idea like net neutrality or refugee support or a vision to
end human trafficking.
That guy on the lower left is my Google brand studio colleague Ruben Santa's.
Hi Ruben,
who joined a team of eight Googlers in Nepal for a 20% project with [inaudible]
dot org to fight human trafficking.
They met with girls in safe houses who had escaped slavery and are now studying
learning vocational skills and becoming advocates for girls still in captivity.
Yeah.
Ruben and the Google team used their everyday problem solving skills to support
some of the NGOs making an impact on the ground.
Okay.
I asked Ruben to describe the impact of the trip on him personally and he
answered me with this photo.
Okay.
Another Google Brand Studio Coworker Ryan Chin,
just came back from a 20% project with net hope.
An organization that sets up Wifi at refugee camps in Greece.
This is a camp inside a departure hall in Greece for Afghan refugees
between interviewing refugees.
He would decompress by drawing.
People started looking over his shoulder and asking if he would draw them.
That's Ryan in the middle.
So he started sharing his pictures with the people around him,
people living in tents who had almost nothing but they had rations.
And because it's human nature to reciprocate,
he was invited for tea.
So Ryan drew even more pictures and as host shared even more of their stories
with him.
And this is Mustafa holding one of Ryan's drawings.
Yeah.
Ryan graciously allowed me to share some of his pictures with you today so that
you can start to get to know refugees as he did.
And maybe some of you will want to volunteer with net hope and install a more
routers and more refugee camps.
Okay.
I wish I could draw like Ryan,
but I can't.
My passions are simpler.
Like corn.
I was raised in a corn growing country in Indiana,
and two big upsides of humid,
who's your summers were one diving into limestone quarry pools and to corn on
the cob.
Turns out Cory jumping.
It's kind of dangerous and technically illegal and tasty corn is getting harder
to find.
In the 1980s most farms in my county were bought out by agribusiness and now the
corn and my county is the kind used for cattle feed and those compostable
takeout boxes.
But when harvest time comes around,
I still crave corn.
So I did my research to find out where farmers still grow tasty heirloom corn,
like the kind I ate as a kid.
The answer Google gave me Wahaca Mexico.
Okay Google,
so how do I get to that corner?
Yeah,
turns out global exchange was organizing a trip to Wahaca for day of the dead.
I don't go for organized trips.
It's my job to organize other people's trips,
but global exchange does fantastic research tracking food justice initiatives,
the itinerary they suggested included visits to a taqueria that exclusively uses
rare varietals of corn.
They have 33 different corns on that menu and this is an image from day of the
dead.
This young woman is dressed and address made entirely of corn husks and corn
kernels.
You can see some of the different colors of the heirloom corn is grown in a
while ago,
but even more importantly,
the trip introduced me to Zappo tech farmers who started seeing cord bank seed
corn banking to preserve heirloom varietals.
When I got a whiff of that corn cooking,
I thought,
yeah,
this,
I get it.
This is food worth fighting for and this is food worth saving for future
generations.
So thank you Google.
I finally found that corn I've been craving,
but I also found my new food heroes.
Yeah.
Now back to you
already.
You have a full suitcase,
solid background research on sustainable travel,
an itinerary with a rural area where you're planning to ask bonus questions and
a passion you're ready to pursue to the ends of the earth.
But there is one last thing you can share.
The thing that Google shares every day,
okay?
You know this one information.
This is a an Italian muralist.
It says,
um,
uh,
let's all give each other a hand.
MMM.
So as part of the application to join that global exchange trip to Wahaca,
they asked me what I was going to do with the information I gathered in stories.
I heard.
Look,
here I am telling you about it.
So that's one promise I've kept today.
Yeah.
But there are other ways to circulate information.
You know,
the drill right posts,
host Wikipedia hack days to correct misinformation and add to our global
knowledge about remote places that may not have access to information sharing
directly.
Reuben put together this crowdfunding campaign for effect.org and he whizzed
past his goal.
Um,
but I promised him I'd say this,
you can still donate and volunteer with effect.org.
So Ruben,
that's another promise I've kept today.
Or you can do what Ryan did and volunteer to install Wifi for people who really
need it.
This boy drew his family a house with the crayons Ryan brought notice it has a w
net hope wifi access points.
Join no networks with the people you meet.
Widen the circle to make room for people to be heard and get to know each other.
You'll learn stuff including some really random facts about breathing tubes and
go chase and you'll make friends for life.
And one day after all this travel,
you may be invited to hang out with people whose work you sincerely admire,
people you've been meaning to thank for a while and you won't have to show up
empty handed or wind up bringing tee shirts.
No one wants,
you'll have some information they might actually be able to use to help them
make their next trip more meaningful.
This just happened to me.
Next time it's your turn.
Let's make this exponential.
Okay,
one last thing.
I'm headed to Uganda next month to work on a cervical cancer awareness campaign.
So if you have family or friends in Uganda,
I like to take you for lunch.
You out for lunch.
And when I offered to deliver a Momento to your friends and family in Uganda,
you know,
I mean it.
Thank you.
Tying with the message that you said and how it relates to the creation of the
books.
You know,
the,
the idea to go one,
you know,
tenant attacks your miles down the road and,
and you know,
how,
how do you balance that with,
um,
you know,
now everybody's going 10 x or miles down the road and they're all selling.
Um,
you have specialty heirloom corn and,
you know,
how,
how do you,
you know,
not,
not overwhelm and keep pushing the frontiers right now when you suggest that
people go places?
Well,
the,
the other part of that,
um,
going further is asking more,
right?
So you don't just go for the corn.
Um,
you meet the farmers and then you asked the farmers what,
what else was happening in the communities.
And suddenly some of the slides I didn't put in here.
They say,
well,
you know,
uh,
I like to do woodwork in my spare time.
Oh,
duty.
You know,
and it turns out that,
you know,
the farmers in this village where I went for the corn,
let's be honest.
Um,
have fantastic,
I mean,
it,
it's a surprise.
It's not sort of UNESCO a claimed are preserved.
It's just a matter of time really.
But it's um,
uh,
farmers have been doing woodworking in that area for hundreds of years now and
donating it to the local church.
So the woodworking splendid,
right?
So you just keep asking more people and you say,
Oh,
well anybody else making interesting food or doing something interesting in
their spare time and they will point you towards the next village and they will
point you towards the,
you know,
their cousin across the valley who makes this really interesting corn drink
fermented.
That's a more powerful than you expect.
That was tasty but strong.
So yeah,
just keep continuing,
use your curiosity to keep,
to keep pushing past the limit.
And it doesn't,
it certainly,
it doesn't take a journalistic background to do that.
It just takes your sort of natural,
the curiosity that you apply every work,
every day at work here,
uh,
to your travel.
Thank you for presenting.
It's great to hear your information and how to do it.
How do you manage the language barriers or differences to really getting in and
understanding the culture and meeting the people who may not speak the languages
that you do?
Yeah.
So it is helpful to do some,
some language learning before you,
before you go,
if you can,
especially if you know you're going to be going to remote areas,
but there's nothing preventing anyone from hiring a local translator or guide.
I mean,
there are fixers who are,
who are used to this kind of thing,
um,
who you can hire as an independent traveler.
Um,
I just lucked out that,
you know,
when I was referred to a series of,
of,
uh,
translators,
um,
somebody said,
well,
this guy is really more of a geologist.
And I said,
Aha.
Because I knew the area that we were going to,
um,
was this,
this is known for,
um,
uh,
having prehistoric fossil sites.
And I knew that I would want to see what other types of information I could get
out of him as a local expert.
So it's trying to find,
you know,
trying to see if you can double up,
can the person who's taking you someplace also provide you with some additional
language learning?
Do they have insights from their own interests or careers or background that
they can bring to that,
that story for you?
Um,
and also,
you know,
again,
because you don't want to rely on locals to give you all this information
triangulate.
Um,
see if you can make connections with places that you're going.
So instead of saying,
okay,
take me to wherever is important.
And then somebody takes you just to the one famous mosque in town and meanwhile
you're passing right by this phenomenal,
you know,
school where in [inaudible] where they,
um,
where adults are doing vocational training and lifelong learning and offering
tea to passers by.
You know.
So,
um,
if you don't leave it entirely up to your local expert but find it,
try to make some local contacts and find some information about where you're
headed.
Um,
dem not also turns out,
in addition to having this phenomenal school,
um,
it is renowned for its olive oil and a particular type of couscous,
which remains to this day.
Like I dream about that cause gifts.
So,
uh,
if you do your own kind of background research,
historical research,
you may come across things that even even locals don't know.
Yup.
One last question then.
What we do,
we do consider paths also.
Um,
uh,
we're aware,
particularly in,
in destinations like Morocco where people can be dependent on a guidebook a lot
because,
um,
it's a,
a key source of information.
Uh,
San Francisco,
there's a lot of information available readily online.
Um,
not so much in the kind of outer reaches of the Sahara desert.
So,
um,
uh,
but you have to be mindful,
um,
as a travel writer to constantly be checking and shifting.
So that one,
you know,
you're not enriching the one merchant in town who happens to sell water,
who's in the book.
It's just somebody else also selling water,
you know,
probably.
Can you say,
oh,
along this,
this particular block,
there are several people who sell,
sell water.
So you want to be mindful of not having an undue impact on,
uh,
on a remote community.
Uh,
and again,
like continuing every time to check,
see what's going on,
see how that money is being spent.
You know,
is it,
is it being,
is that the community seeing the benefit or is it really just that one water
seller?
Um,
we had,
um,
there's a,
a story in Morocco.
Um,
there was an oasis that gets bypassed because it's not along a side road was
built,
a bigger road was built.
And so now this town that has a bit historic ag Dez has been completely
bypassed.
And,
uh,
I thought,
hmm,
I want to,
I want to find out what's going on there.
And I had done some,
some research with nonprofits and they said,
yeah,
there's a,
there's a community garden that's opened up there.
I'm not really sure what they're up to,
but you know,
a few,
few like gardens.
And I knew that,
um,
uh,
English folks who are big audience for lonely planet guidebooks are really
passionate about gardening.
I thought,
I better check out the garden.
So I went and it turns out that it's a communally organized garden that was
started by some teachers who noticed that kids were falling asleep in class.
Um,
and we're not growing very much.
And they realized that it connected with malnourishment.
They weren't getting enough of a range of nutrients to support them in their
development.
And,
uh,
so the community got together and they said,
look,
we've got this patch of land at the center,
we've got one well in town,
maybe we can agree to,
uh,
send some of irrigate that one patch that doesn't belong to any one person and
all grow vegetables together and agree that this is going to be for the families
who need it most.
And then if there's leftover,
then it goes to the,
it's the other families.
And then if there's,
you know,
they couldn't actually imagine a time when there would be leftover after that.
Um,
so I met with them and I said,
you know,
can people come and visit your garden without disrupting your gardening?
Uh,
and they said,
sure.
Anytime.
And I was like,
okay,
well actually it's possible you would get a lot of people interested in this
garden,
so let's,
let's set some times and let's set a meeting place and let's figure out who's
going to be able to let them in and show them around.
Um,
so they,
they thought it was clearly,
they were like,
wow,
this just a garden that we've started in our village on my own.
I can't imagine tourists really want to see it,
but,
okay.
Um,
and the next time I came they said,
first of all,
the garden had grown.
Second of all,
the children had grown and were paying attention in class.
They had a,
they had diverse,
been able to diversify what they were growing from simple sort of beans and root
vegetables.
They were able to grow tomatoes.
They were selling them now to other villages.
So they were able to buy books for the school as well.
So it had this huge knock on effect.
And it was all individual travelers coming through saying,
hey,
um,
we had provided a,
uh,
arrange saying,
you know,
if you want to plant one row of beans,
you could leave a donation of like $5 and that would do that for this community.
And people were crazy generous.
And we're like,
wow,
we want you to be able to do,
grow as much food as your community needs.
Um,
and uh,
and so they were very moved by that.
The next time I came back they said,
okay,
so this is great.
Our,
our community is doing well.
We're able to help out neighboring villages.
Two,
two pilot,
similar projects.
And they said,
but one thing we never realized,
we never thought of ourselves as environmental leaders.
And,
and we've had people come to us from,
from,
you know,
visitors from,
not just from the UK but from Bangladesh,
from Latin America,
from all these other places saying,
we could do this in the place that I'm from.
Do you mind if I borrow this idea?
And very open source.
So they're like,
yes,
we'll tell you how to do it.
We'll tell you how to scale it.
We now have expertise to offer,
right?
We can,
we can help you model this.
So that all happened just because there was,
you know,
I was thinking actually of our users,
I was thinking of British people being interested in gardens,
and in fact,
it had this tremendous impact.
Um,
uh,
and that's something that anybody could do.
It doesn't have to be,
um,
you all have a phenomenal platform.
Um,
and you invent new platforms all the time.
So thinking creatively about how you can support an effort that is ongoing.
Like that's,
that's,
that's just what you do at Google.
Um,
you think about users all the time.
So if you think about your travel the same way,
what can you do?
What small thing can you do?
What platform can you provide?
Um,
it's a,
it's a powerful tool.
Thank you very much.
Thanks so much,
cliff.
[inaudible].